hello and welcome to see your plane caps
2015 and color Louie I remember that I
think he plays the Yates variation nope
ok so the brea it is still haven't
gotten around to learn it properly I'd
have to admit but I i get x by x playing
somewhat normal looking moves it's not
really satisfactory but results are not
that bad in my blitz games at least
yeah the problem with those lines with
black is a little bit if you don't study
it correctly you play sort of yeah
normal-looking moves but there are
subtleties it's not like yeah you can
play whatever and and and be in good
shape and this is the thing these are
subtleties they are not not yet online
on my radar I just play what looks kind
of okay but that doesn't mean that it is
ok then what about this though it's a
four really that that pic a deal I don't
think so i think i will get a good
control over he five so don't fear this
that much oh my god what you got to be
killing me i may be dangerous ok anyway
um I can absolutely not not take I have
to take so let's take what now we should
see 89 h 6 mm is dangerous but let's say
I go here and I GA next depends a bit on
this move now Queenie ax 3 I guess neji
8 Queen g3 I ok it's blitz chess you can
try many things in blitz 96 might even
be a move
yep so we took this one okay my rook is
hanging I can't think I'll just cover
this
now very very dangerous sacrifice it's
probably even objectively okay and in
the Blitz game it's downright downright
annoying how to defend but what is the
defense here if hear me at least he
takes time here if I get some time I
play Queen d8 I guess okay i don't get
the time here text my night ok so what
to do night a4 looks like putting it
totally on the edge of the board but
it's okay i don't i don't see I don't if
I go back I'm blocking this Bishop from
going to see eight and I need the bishop
on see aid in case of night f5 that I
can go Bishop c8 I think you might just
take be five no he goes f4 Oh God and if
I take it I'm going to get killed you
because of a five
so nigh g8 okay our position looks
ridiculous completely completely without
any harmony and coordination and I
cannot move my queen due to that Bishop
1c8 being under attack there Wow f6
looks looks like the worst move ever now
still I have to cover you five I mean
it's really it's super ugly and we can
even play five Queen g6 stuff no it
takes that pawn okay okay okay 97's the
thing from 96 maybe on hmm and still I
wait Queenie aid is a queen trade right
it takes text XXX that's a queen trade
okay that that I have to do I simply
have to do it even if this is still not
great i'm at my night is just hanging
hahaha oh no I just landed a full night
here fantastic fantastic how ridiculous
ah ok it was a super tough position to
play absolutely ok
how many points the ton of porn sundown
the only thing is time wise i'm quite ok
but the position sucks I mean big time
you can take here maybe try to try to
get to that porn I wake chua Lee I'm
just missing things left and right I
wanted to play Bishop f ages to c5 for
this is of course absolutely not
happening and he's got rookie to around
the corner okay I probably have to do
this try to get this dangerous porn just
to try to survive okay now okay if I
take this route 27 check
there should be five check okay um time
mornings move the king mmm can I move
them then take d 7 I wouldn't work out
ok I have to take
check check night I could have taken
this it would have been I'd better check
check draw off her check check mate ok
ah yeah I really fight hot now for the
high school I really don't care so much
about the time what time is wrong I just
want to want to score here now okay I
just I just deservedly loss I lost this
game Wow night f5 I mean at least in a
blitz game this is this is a super tough
super-tough too tough to defend now I
mean it makes some sense out of night eh
form ok maybe I should just play a
prophylactic move I mean and when I
didn't see the idea I thought he wanted
to go F form and yeah you can do
something like that and just yeah make
this impossible that he this is this is
defending it quite quite easily ok so we
played this and well my daughter work
objectively but it's it's very tough to
play
after this 96 I am gross already so the
computer wants to defend with this I did
not want to do that simply because of
this check but there's king of eight arm
that says every wed stupid that's stupid
that I didn't consider this one I was
just thinking okay I'll take and he
takes and my king is a mess or King f8
is more or less winning for black I
thinking I mean this is a relatively
clear piece that's not enough
compensation so probably I have to do
this and he will probably take and this
is a much better version of the game of
course so it came I suspected that this
95 it's not objectively correct but in a
blitz game it was a very good try and we
saw that I pretty clearly yeah lost lost
my composure them night between maybe
it's better that's what the engine wants
to do and it makes some sense with this
we actually cover here this is just bull
now I came once I did not see the best
defense and then i blundered i was so
happy to spot a creep rate that i
blundered the night yeah the position is
just too bad i have a completely
ridiculous looking position with with f
6 h-6 and everything's wrong okay thanks
for watching